so let's talk about something serious
though this is amazing so six uh degrees
your organization um we did something
earlier today but talk about like what
what's the purpose why did you want to
do this well sixdegrees.org is a is a
charitable organization we started in
2017 and uh this this uh
2024 is the 40th anniversary of a
certain movie that I did uh that where
there might have
been yeah there might have been barns
going on and so uh we launched this
initiative to build uh 40,000 kits um
and these are kits where that are in
bags or backpacks that get distributed
to people that need essential items you
know whether they be um uh not doing
well struggling uh you unhoused whatever
it happens to be children sometimes who
you know can't afford them or going off
to school and uh so today with your
beautiful crowd yeah um we actually
built uh 200 bags super cool man yeah
let's talk about your podcast it's is
six degrees with Kevin Bacon right yeah
six deg what are Y what do you talk
about uh it's it's it's a podcast where
in the first half of it I discuss um
with celebrities whether they are uh
actors or or musicians uh dancer people
from Sports reality television comedians
uh we just kind of shoot the Bree we
talk about whatever connections we might
have things that that you know either in
terms of having work together or
whatever and the second half of it is we
talk about the organizations that they
are connected to either they're on the
board or it's a foundation that they've
actually started and we bring the person
on to the podcast who runs their
foundation so that they get a microphone
in front of them someone that do get the
spotlight get the spotlight yeah and um
so it's a lot about kind of uh bringing
some attention to things that
celebrities care about other than the
clothes that they wear or the
restaurants that they go yeah speaking
of good causes tomorrow is giving
Tuesday everybody a movement that
encourages people and organizations to
positively transform communities across
the world we can do it so building kits
uh by Kevin Bacon a campaign so how how
can people get involved other than
showing up to be an audience member at
my show yeah well that's that's that's a
great start um there's a there's a few
different ways uh one is that if you
have an organization wherever it is in
in in in the country that that has a
need even during this um bag building uh
someone reached out to our six deges
person and said I got an organization in
Seattle that could really use something
like this going on yeah so that's one
way you can go to sixdegrees.org and and
and connect with us that way you can
also donate for sure we need to raise
money to to buy the essentials to buy
the bags we do have as many corporate
sponsorships and Partnerships as we
possibly can um you know the bomba Socks
today came from bomba and uh for
instance um and and the Third Way is in
your communities if you hear about this
going on to just volunteer and doesn't
cost you anything you show up you take
the things you put them in the bag and
it's a great sense of satisfaction that
you feel when you've you know my brother
and I were down in um DC playing a bacon
brother show and we showed up it took us
whatever an hour of our day you know
where we're sitting around waiting for
soundcheck to uh just go and hang out
with some people and put some stuff in
some bags and then the the satisfaction
of turning around and seeing 300 bags
that are going to go to kids that are
that are struggling in in the DC area
it's a great it's a great feeling
absolutely well as we mentioned earlier
before the show our audience Uh Kevin
and I all got together to help out with
his building kits campaign so here's how
that
went I'm excited thank you so much for
doing this I think this is the coolest
thing ever we're building things yeah
we're building bags so they don't know
well they do
[Applause]
now here we're excited for the show
obviously too but we I'm super excited
I've never gotten to do anything like
this yet so I'm excited this is all
Kevin's idea by the way it's amazing cuz
he had this idea for us to pack bags
like all the essentials like toothpaste
deodorant and we had the audience we
already have all these people here
what's up everybody something like this
is very very simple and it also
effective yeah and it's it brings people
together everybody you just put one
thing from each basket right yep one
thing from each basket look at you right
they're all essential things that people
need I was the one that needed help when
I was younger so we we needed the help
we needed the essentials we needed all
that stuff this is awesome why don't you
guys come down this side then we can
just make an assembly line just pass
them down oh yeah if y'all down this way
here I'll go down here thank you thank
you we also put in like a handwritten
note of any kind of inspiration that
that that you can you can find you know
I mean I just hang in there I want our
recipients receive these kids with a
handwritten note from the person that
packed them that shows them that
somebody really cares it's powerful it
reminds the recipient that there's a
real person on the other side of those
kits it's just another detail for people
who were maybe just having a rough day
or a rough time in their life hey guys
thank you so much this was all Kevin you
was the one who came up with
this thank you for being a
morning thank you all so much appreciate
it thank you thanks for your
work all right so let's talk to some of
the people who helped with the badge
this morning I'm GNA start with Britney
so Britney what was the experience like
for you well Kelly I really enjoyed
working with you and Kevin this morning
building the bags um as a military
spouse we just love coming together for
one mission for giving Tuesday to
intentionally give back and connect our
communities um my favorite part of this
morning was adding the personal note in
there to really make it had that
Personal Touch um mine said you matter
on it and I feel like something simple
is absolutely and thank you for your
family service that's amazing thank you
thank you Bry Teresa also wanted to
share her experience so Teresa why don't
you tell us what it was like um so the
experience was by far was very welcome
and warming um this really resonated um
with me um growing up I was in a single
parent household and we also dependent
on charity and donations and state and
all that and one of the things that I
really liked was the Comon card because
we can give and we can receive but words
of wisdom just writing something and
saying keep the faith everything's going
to be okay God's with you and the
encouragement goes further sometimes
than just actually receiving a pair of
socks yeah somebody took a minute to
write it you know saying it's not an
email it's not anything like that it's
like person experience coming here was
just amazing that's it's so funny you
pointed that out but I feel like it is a
lot of people when you grow up without
yes then you know what that's like
exactly so when you're blessed then you
know that you need to give because you
were that person on the other side
that's I mean it's kind of odd but I'm
almost really thankful for it because I
understand like the need so it's it's a
a really important thing that not
everybody gets you know um which you're
kind of happy about but then you're also
like hey think outside yourself um well
before before we get to break can you
tell me what was going on um in that
podcast clip your wife was in it yeah
yeah that was a kind of a special
episode where uh she was the guest and
we highlighted actually our foundation
sixdegrees.org and Stacy Houston who who
runs the foundation was there and um
it's it's it's I mean it was fun to it
was unusual to have you ever interviewed
her before no no I have not no I mean
unless we're talking about breakfast I
mean but but I didn't know like if a
magazine ever you know sometimes they
have like stars interview Stars I didn't
know they ever think so no I don't think
they've ever asked us to do that and we
don't do that much together frankly you
know we don't do we do everything
together but we don't that I appreciate
that though you have your separate lie
that's cool yeah yeah that's important
that's why you're still married maybe
yeah maybe yeah
Independence well let's take a short
break everybody check out Kevin's
podcast six degrees with Kevin Bacon
wherever you get your podcast and go
online to find out how you can join
Kevin and six degrees in their campaign
to provide 40,000 essential care
[Music]
kits
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home